this is a production of Cornell
University
for those of you that don't know me my
name is Jason and I am the coordinator
for the insect diagnostic lab and the
collection manager for the Cornell
University insect collection so the two
jobs wrapped into one what I'll do over
the next little while is is discuss some
of the things that I've been getting
over the past few months in here that
might be of interest to you and then I'm
very keen to hear what you've been
getting and I'd be keen to get any
questions that you might have so don't
be shy there's no such thing as a stupid
question I get a lot of really good
questions from people that submit things
so I guess the first thing that comes to
mind for me it's very fresh in my mind
is hemlock woolly adelgid which I'm sure
many of you have been experiencing it
just finally spread to my yard a few
days ago or at least I noticed it a few
days ago and I I live in a neighborhood
where the Neighborhood Association sent
out a strongly worded email warning
against treating your trees for hemlock
adelgid and one of my concerned
neighbors thought it was a little
sketchy that they were so strongly
against it and yeah i did a fact check
on it and it just didn't stand up on
many levels but I you know I respect
people's right to treat or not treat my
neighbor and I share to hemlock trees
and we chatted over barbecue last night
that we will treat them and that the the
cost-benefit analysis sort of strongly
ways in favor of treating them probably
thematic co-producer neyo nick has
anybody else been seeing hemlock woolly
adelgid in their counties recently
this is Joyce from Duchess we've had it
for years because especially along the
Hudson River where it's warmer was where
we first saw a lot of damage on some of
the stately old hemlocks along with some
of the historical sites it's come out
throughout the county in about every
third year there's another article and
one thing I would like to say is when
the article came out last year an
elderly couple came in and they were
almost ready to weep that they had this
wonderful hedge and it was going to be
destroyed and what would they do and I
took them outside to the hemlocks that
are here at our farm and home center and
we've had hemlock woolly adelgid for
5-10 years it's weakened the tree but I
was able to show them what to look for
and asked them to go scout before they
hired someone to spray so if it's new to
your area i would say that people
shouldn't overreact and they should
understand what it is they're looking
for and understand that it doesn't
necessarily kill the things overnight in
my drink thanks Joyce I'm really keen to
hear what the mortality is like in
certain areas now the two trees that we
are going to treat our pretty weekend to
start with they might not even be worth
saving it's debatable but do you see
much mortality at all like if you had to
give a rough percentage what would you
say what would you say oh what we see is
they thin over several years and get to
the point where they're starting to look
ratty enough that people take them down
the ones here at our building because
it's a county building there's they're
quite thinned with maybe a third of the
tops gone and the bottoms are still
green enough that no one has deemed them
to be worthy of damage you know that
they're going to fall down or at the
risk of causing damage okay thank you
and Jason here as a hiker and a person
who frequents trout streams I'm seeing a
lot of mortality on his big old
beautiful hemlock forests on the North
Slope
in these kind of you know more untended
areas and so they go they do die yeah
nope okay um well thank you for that I'm
I'm really quite curious to see sort of
where the hemlocks are dying and as I
think you guys have mentioned I suspect
it's not a hundred percent mortality and
you know I guess sort of as we're
experiencing with things like Beach Park
disease we're going to eventually select
for more tolerant genotypes that will
survive the outbreak and it is it is sad
to see some of these really old stately
hemlocks ago and I'm just curious to see
what the potential introduction of
natural enemies will eventually do to it
for those who are unaware there's a
small beetle called layar copious that's
been introduced that loves hemlock
woolly adelgid and there's also little
cam ayad fly that we're looking at
introducing the interesting thing with
the canon lide fly it's not been
recorded for New York State but we do
have specimens in the collection from
Pennsylvania so it's pretty close by so
it's more of a jurisdictional thing that
we have to seek permission to bring it
into new york state even though it
probably does already occur here it's
just our knowledge of smaller flies is
pretty sparse now it's going to unless
there's further questions what hemlock
woolly adelgid there is a comment about
winter cut worms and I was quite
fascinated by that because most of you
probably have realized a fairly recent
invasive here called noctua / nuba the
common name unfortunately is the large
yellow underwing it's not related to any
of our native under wings is a type of
cutworm but it's got bright orange
hindwings with a black border the four
rings quite variable in pattern can be
from a dull orangish brown to a modeled
darker brownish almost black that
species was introduced into Halifax Nova
Scotia that would have been I think in
the 70s and it's sort of sat in Nova
Scotia as as a number of invasives have
and then for some reason or another just
boomed westward and then in the early
1990s it showed up in Ontario that's
where I was collecting moths when I was
younger and it just became abundant
immediately and then within a few years
I think by the year 2000 it had made it
right to the Pacific coast I've heard
from people that were doing experiments
here at Cornell that the year that
species showed up it just wiped out
various experiments it's just a standard
cutworm just like some of our other pest
species but the quite noticeable in that
the larvae are sometimes act of
midwinter if you get a about a warm
weather or about a freezing rain or
something that they seem to come out and
march around now they can be separated
from similar cut worms that are native
by they're usually a little bit bigger
overall that's sort of hard to judge
though but the key character to look at
is the markings along the side of the
body you're going to see a series of
black rectangles that go from about a
third of the way back right to the very
end and those black rectangles are quite
prominent they're the only really
distinct marking and if you've got that
you've got knocked to a pro nuba I just
want to verify was that the winter
cutworm you were talking about yeah this
was Joyce and because my focus is um is
consumer I had a woman call and said my
my beagles are eating these cat these
caterpillars no she called him carms and
they're throwing up what are they and
are they poisonous so I'm going in my
little diagnostic lab and looking them
up and she said she actually had she
brought in the the samples and they were
fast little buggers once they got warm
it was in january and i finally emerged
all happy and I went down to our
agriculture colleagues who said oh yeah
that's winter cutworms so they knew it
from a a crop pests and I had to see
grow you know by myself but it was
because it was in some lawn and the dogs
were eating it and I did find the
University of Michigan article from
several years ago I think they're just
so active it causes the dogs to throw up
so that's how I learned
about the winter cover interesting I
really like that common name as you
probably know with insects common names
unless it's a major pest species are
next to useless they vary from place to
place and I like that name because it
actually makes sense because it is a
type of cut room and their most
prominent winter you can find them sort
of pretty much any months of the year
they're multi volton here they several
generations a year but the winter they
just really stick out like a sore thumb
that's really interesting and I I do
wonder if they're chemically protected
they might be but I suspect they're
probably not I get a lot of queries here
in the diagnostic lab from a few
different organic producers so they are
specially distributors where they buy
organic produce they distribute it it's
sold a customer finds a bug in their
salad and they complain and sometimes
threaten to sue and the question that
the distributor wants to know well
there's three questions they want to
know first question is what is it second
question is where is it from and third
question is how dangerous is it and the
first answer it varies if they can send
me something or not usually it's a
grainy cellphone pic of a black speck
that may or may not be an insect if they
send me a specimen usually can get some
sort of name on it the second question
where is it from unfortunately answer
almost always is wherever that crop is
grown because a lot of these pests are
pretty widespread and the third answer
that I say sort of semi sarcastically is
choice edible most of these crop pests
are perfectly edible and you're unlikely
to die if you consume it there's been a
few where it's like okay yeah that will
make your stomach upset if you eat it
however as soon as your tongue hits it
it's going to realize that tastes really
bad and it's it's sort of amazing to me
how some consumers just overreact to a
bug in their salad and I think it's
really unfortunate and we really need to
educate people that you know it's it's
meet you know if you're as long as
you're not vegetarian or vegan you know
it shouldn't be a huge issue just either
throw the salad out or and get a refund
or you know just ignore it kind of thing
not we're not winter moths this here or
we're not winter muahz I don't mean that
winter cutworm but we have we are now
dealing with like a spring emergence of
things like stoneflies and huge numbers
we have a lot of rivulet to the streams
and wet areas and I had a pest pro come
in yesterday with some stoneflies and he
the customer wanted him to spray the
entire outside of his house to kill them
all and they were just you know resting
on the yellow siding so we do get that
kind of we don't know what it is there's
a lot of it and shouldn't we just kill
it sigh and yes sadly as you can imagine
I deal with those as well to the more
amenable recent ones there was someone
submitted springtails that were all over
her deck last year and she wanted to
know how to get rid of them was like
well you could nuke your soil but I
really don't recommend it you know
that's they are natural part of your
soil you know get used to it once it
dries out they'll they'll be gone but
the most dramatic example was a pest
control company in new york city called
me up and said okay listen we're calling
up by by request of our clients we don't
really think there's any need to do
anything they sent me photos of it what
it was is the top floor of a skyscraper
adjacent to Central Park that on the
outsides of the windows that are not
open about their work Newman wasps and
lots of them and the people that were
working in the top floor of that
building wanted the building sprayed
because there are wasps on the outside
of the windows and it just it baffled me
I had a very interesting chat with the
pest control operator and basically
encouraged to give them literature on
what these acknow- wasps actually do and
that they're not dangerous at all
especially since there's no way for the
people to be even in contact with them
it was just it seems like the sight of
them was was just enough
so I think what I'll do I'll open it up
to questions anybody have any sort of
questions for me what this is Joyce talk
to us about focus experience with
earthworms and or invasive earthworms
what's going on with that so that's a
really interesting topic and I can't
claim to be an expert on it but it's a
topic that that's near and dear to my
heart in New York State as i'm sure many
of you know there are no native
earthworms they were wiped out by the
previous glacial period they would have
probably eventually made it back here
the expansion rate for earthworms is
typically about a meter or a yard a year
depending on the species we either on
purpose or by accident have introduced a
number of species of earthworms into New
York State originally from Europe and
more recently several Asian species now
in the garden in general and our firms a
great thing you know the good decomposes
they build soils fantastic there's some
strong arguments that earthworms can be
quite detrimental to certain forest
systems and where I used to work up in
algonquin park in Ontario where again
there's no native earthworms you can
actually see the expansion ring of where
earth rooms have been dropped from
someone's bait bucket on some of the
lakes because there's a very limited
settlement history there there were no
earthworms and people have dumped bait
buckets and you can see a ring where the
inside of the ring the leaf litter lasts
less than a season after that the leaf
litter accumulates for about three years
now the effects of this is it does
change things so first of all when you
get rid of the leaf litter yes you do
have that nutrient pulse but it also
causes the soil to dry out in the later
summer which is a drier time of the year
up there which can dry out some of the
the soil organisms as well as some of
the seedlings it does also change over
probably long periods of time the forest
composition so with that typical three
or Duff layer up there only really big
deeds get established are really well
nourished seed so things like sugar
maple and Beach are the dominant trees
other things like Eastern hemlock yellow
birch and eastern white pine either
depend on disturbance like small ground
fires or getting established on rocks
and logs as they commonly are up there
so this is changing the composition to
favor so these smaller seeded trees and
also further south in southern Ontario
it's favoring things like ash which now
is being nailed by emerald ash borer so
it's it's definitely having impact there
in studies in Michigan they're showing
that certain types of the tricky and
some of the the grape ferns that are
quite rare are being negatively affected
by it they also depend on thick Duff
layers of leaves to to protect them from
competition from other so smaller seated
plants so the effects depend on what
habitat you're talking about but
definitely they are changing my
suspicion is that they're really changed
in the invertebrate composition of leaf
litter in forest systems case in point
that before earthworms are here probably
the biggest macro decomposes of dead
leaves on the forest floor were specific
types of caterpillars there's whole
group of caterpillars called her minions
are called leaf litter moths they're
still around they're still fairly common
but they probably were the major
decomposes but they're not as efficient
as earthworms this kept a very complex
intact habitat loss of habitat for
things like ground beetles and other
insects that live in the soil so I
suspect there's some huge effects now as
far as rhythms getting dispersed they're
very easy to disperse especially you
know bringing soil and things like that
but in studies done in northern Alberta
they found that you can find earthworms
speckled along the distribution of
logging roads and that worm eggs really
strongly adhere to the tread of truck
tires and so trucks are distributing
them just by just by driving from places
with or in terms to places without does
that sort of answer your questions
this is oh joy situation because thank
you because for the others listening it
is interesting when someone calls up and
says on a rainy day and says my lawn is
moving what do I do well help your life
I don't know hissar well go ahead you
brought something up Jason as we are
we're talking to folks about creating
backyard biodiversity and building
habitat things like ground beetles that
are great predators you know they're
losing their kind of losing their
habitat because of these worms and you
know understanding those beetles a
little bit more knowing what they like I
think that you know it's part of our
part of our messaging how do you how do
you build a good habitat in your
backyard and it sounds like they need
brushy kind of cover and loose debris
that they can hide and hang out in and I
think there's there's two points I want
to make here that that discussion
spurred one is why you see earth worms
crawling around on the surface of the
ground on rainy days I used to believe
as do I think many other people that it
was because oh well it's raining they'll
drown down there that's actually not
true they actually can survive perfectly
fine as long as the souls not constantly
saturated they can do just fine in fact
I recall going for a hike back in my
undergrad and just pondering how do
worms cross streams and then looking
down as I was crossing a bridge and
seeing earthworms on the bottom of the
stream wiggling a long ago okay that's
how they swim the real reason why they
come out on really rainy days is most
species use that as a time to mate and
disperse and so it's much more efficient
to travel across the surface of the
ground than underground and because its
raining its moist enough that they're
not going to get to desiccated being
above ground so that's the main
dispersal thing the second thing was on
ground beetles and I'm sure most of you
have seen them if you want to see how
common ground beetles are in an area go
out at night get a headlamp and just
shine at the ground they have really
distinctive I science to
dots that will look right back at you if
you see six or eight dots those are
typically wolf spiders also quite common
at night if you sample the ground
beetles the crabbits of your backyard
unfortunately what you'll find unless
you're out in a pristine wild area is
most of the dominant species are
European in origin they've really taken
over especially in disturbed habitats
and especially in agricultural habitats
now if you want to promote ground beetle
diversity in your backyard basically you
need a place for them to hide most of
the species that are there are nocturnal
and during the day they hide under logs
and rocks and what I always advise
people when I especially when I do
Master Gardener trainings when I talk
about how to promote having beneficial
insects and gardens like ground beetles
is have a place for them to live you
know surround your garden by things like
cobblestones cobblestones are great in
Easter rocks and he's sort of debris
that they can go under during the date
is fantastic and and the cool thing
about that is for people that are really
curious about what's there at night is
you can lift those cobblestones up and
have a look at all the things that hide
there during the day and the majority of
those things will be beneficial insects
or at least neutral now some things like
some of the cut worms will use that but
on the balance I'd say it's it's
generally beneficial to have places for
things to hide the number one enemy to
allow these beneficial insects is just
lawns lawns are just biodiversity
deserts really
comments or further questions on that or
something else this is Joyce I'm sorry
to be noisy i have a photo of the
cutworm if I could share can someone
give me the ball interesting yeah yeah
now to me that actually might not be not
to a pronoun but it's hard to tell so it
does have those rectangles but they're
just not quite right that might be
another one called speed Lauda's
clandestina and the clandestine dart I'm
sure it has another common name as well
which is a native species I I'd have to
compare to literature on that one when
when I looked at them yeah when I looked
at it I threw it out and then when I
called her I said send me photos so
these are the only two photos I have but
it's what her dog was eating Wow so yeah
not sure i'd have to see cutworm
identification can be challenging it's
probably not to our new beau yeah it's
probably knocked to a pronoun but I we
have a lot of folks emailing us photos
now we've gotten past the asking them to
put the ants on the phone so that they
can tell us what who they are so they're
sending us photograph and then we Oh
generally we always try to get them to
follow up with a sample or stop by
because I think that people are going
more and more to the Internet to just
you know they're trolling you're just
finding everything and then they're
getting really confused and you know
they've got this thing and then when you
look into it it's you know only from
South America and you know I are you see
are you getting a lot of that too and
Jason are you're getting a lot of
samples I a photo absolutely that's
becoming I've been here for four years
and I'd say even in that short time it's
it's drastically increased and I
encourage people to submit photos
because quite often we can at least
alleviate some of their fears one of the
most common things people you know
submit to the
diagnostic lab is they are worried about
bedbugs and so will send a photo of
domestic and right away I can say okay
no that's not a bedbug it's a domestic
you could submit I can tell you what
kind and where you might want to look
for it kind of thing I had an
interesting question yesterday I was
giving a collection to her to soils
class and one of the students asked me
okay so we have this lovely thing called
the internet and Google why should
people submit something to the
diagnostic lab and my answer was quite
similar to yours that well for some
things absolute you get a big shoe a
butterfly you can consult the internet
and probably get a reasonable answer for
it especially if you've got a background
to entomology you can sort of figure or
know the reputable websites but you can
find this as you all know there's so
much garbage out there so for instance
when someone submits springtails I send
the little blurb back on springtails and
what to do you know kind of thing but I
always have to put the cave yet by the
way spring tells do not breed under your
skin and if you google springtails
unfortunately you will find articles
that say yes they do you'll also find
articles that say their government
conspiracies and that they're implanting
fibers in your brain and controlling
things now granted most people will sort
of laugh at the last view but there's a
few that go down that route and I spend
a fair bit of time on the phone
especially in the winter with people
that have gone you know down the rabbit
hole and it can be really challenging to
convince them that well eh I'm not part
of the conspiracy and be that some of
these websites are you know blowing hot
air that there's there's really nothing
to it saying that I think it is really
valuable and for some people that submit
stuff I'm just surprised that they
didn't google it like some of them are
just so obvious like if you had let's
say a pest on your hibiscus it's it's
pretty easy to google pest hibiscus and
there's a good chance you'll get a
reasonable answer not always but usually
and some just you know submit really
distinctive things and the ones that I
find don't use the googles and talk to
me first I tend to be sort of on the
older end of things and just not so
internet savvy and some of the the the
ones that are really susceptible to
paranoia tend to not even have email so
I have to talk to them either in person
or or on the phone I'll have one more
with what seems to be an early spring we
here in the Hudson Valley have all sorts
of things blooming and the Red Wings
black birds are back what do you think
we will see as will we see more activity
earlier activity what can we anticipate
in terms of calls and and oh my goodness
what is this in terms of early spring a
very difficult question so as you know
it's really hard to crystal ball these
sort of things with an earlier season
what I would guess is that certain
migratory species that become pests
things like corn earworm armyworm they
might be able to get here earlier and
establish sooner now the big years that
we have for those typically correspond
with really warm winters further south
an ideal conditions for them that aren't
too wet and I think that's the case so
we may see more larger numbers of that
another one that sort of falls into this
pattern is diamondback moth where
they're also generally migratory there
are some exceptional individuals that
can overwinter further north like even
in New York State there are records of
that but it's certainly not normal this
year might be different we only had at
least here in tompkins county we only
had a few quite cold days but that might
not have been cold enough to kill off
things like diamondback moth so it just
sort of advances the season they might
be able to squeeze in another generation
and become more of a problem that way
well otherwise it really depends on how
much moisture because the other thing
that was quite striking about this
winter
at least here in tompkins county is the
very little snow that we got and the
cold snap seemed to really hit the
ground quite hard so you probably
noticed a lot of needle ice this year if
you have bare patches of ground where
you get these sharp IC needles that pop
up with soil capping them that's
basically a condition you get when
you've got no snow cover cold snap and
basically water through capillary action
comes up to the soil and forms these
needles that's really quite damaging to
a lot of insects that just over winter
and the leaf layer in years where you
have a lot of snow cover and the winter
is not exceptionally cold you actually
have insects and especially spiders
active all winter long underneath the
snow and that certainly probably wasn't
the case at least during the cold days
this winter since there was essentially
no snow up here so my long-winded answer
or the short version my long-winded
answer is it's hard to say but I suspect
a few more pestle get an early head
start this year what is the ass for
black legged pig ah black like it ticks
also known as deer ticks I don't know I
I found very few this winter like in
previous winters if I'd go out I'd get a
few on my Eve on warm days in winter
even if it was just slightly below
freezing you'd still get the odd tick
I've seen none this year I know that's
just an anecdote I don't have any real
data to support that so I don't know I
think the only we'll find out is just by
experiencing it I'm more familiar with
some of the other tick species up north
and the big things that seem to knock
them back where the fall conditions and
I'm trying to her back to what our fall
was like the fall conditions being
exceptionally cold and damp were not
friendly to the tix if they were warm
dry falls they seem to do really well
that winter I suspect it's probably
similar for black like it takes I my
short answer is I don't know are there
any
um any kind of hot pests that you hope
you don't get any samples up that we
should be on the lookout for hot pests
that we don't get samples out that we
should be our of that we should be
looking out for there's quite a few bark
beetles that I've been showing up it's i
went to a bark beetle workshop two years
ago in florida and is disturbing how
many new species show up every year
especially in the southeast but also up
here and they can go undetected for many
years so there's a number of bark
beetles that i would worry about but but
quite frankly at this point we have so
many non-native bark beetles here it's
it's except for specific ones I wouldn't
worry too much down towards Long
Island's southern pine beetle has seemed
to spread north and is kneeling a lot of
the pines there I don't know how far
north that one will get that's really
hard to predict that and at least with
the Western counterpart the mountain
pine beetle it's really highly dependent
on a lot of old trees and warm winters
and again this is probably a fairly warm
winter so it might have spread a Fitbit
for the North I don't know how far north
it will get though as far as other
things go I really don't know there is a
new longhorn beetle that has shown up
near New York City in westchester county
and the unfortunate thing is it's so in
distinctive that the way to key it ow is
it lacks all the distinctive features of
all the other species and it's it's been
well established in that yard and I
think it's probably going to spread now
is it going to be a pest on trees maybe
it seems most we're emerging from
firewood but there is some evidence at
least in Utah where it's established
that it can affect fruit trees
negatively beyond that your guess is as
good as mine I really don't know and I
just need
be we all need to be prepared for
anything that sort of new and when I'm
asked the question okay how do you
prepare for the next invasive and the
thing I advise people is be familiar
with what's in your backyard and if
something looks different be suspicious
because these new invasives that become
a problem they tend to show up and show
up very drastically and suddenly and so
they'll stick out to a lot of people we
actually negative impact you some of our
gardens and beneficials do the last no
color a good question i'd say probably
yes and probably know it all depends on
the species the thing with a really
healthy garden the beneficial insects
should be diverse both in diversity of
species and diversity of families and
orders of insects if you depend on one
species let's say one type of ground
beetle chances are some event will knock
them all back with this this weird
winter where we had almost no snow cover
and when it got cold there was no snow
cover it seemed yeah some of the things
will be negatively affected the thing
with a lot of our native species though
is they are adapted to this for the most
part and yeah some will get knocked back
some won't and insect populations will
fluctuate so that's my wishy-washy
answer of maybe maybe not depending
somewhat kind of can you highlight some
of your preferred site for gatherings
and information on their own so I'll
plant a few things so as Laura mentioned
the insect diagnostic lab if you google
insect diagnostic lab cornell you'll
find us we do have fact sheets for a lot
of different insects so you can click on
that and there's is informations a lot
of different groups also there's
information if people want to submit
samples to us or you've got a client
that wants to submit to us if it's a
really difficult sample here's the
information for how to send it it's
really key key to emphasize that I need
the information on where it's from when
it's from kind of thing and also to
package it appropriately it's disturbing
how many people will put an insect wrap
it up in a Kleenex put it in envelope
and send it through the mail and expect
me to piece together a thousand pieces
of insect and try to identify it so
always make sure they put it into some
sort of crush proof container so that's
sort of the shameless self-promotion
aspect of it other than that bug guide
so bug guide net if you've never used
this website use it it's fantastic my
bias is I am one of the editors on this
website but basically what you can do so
if you you're completely clueless you
have no idea what you can do go to ID
request you have to set up an account is
free and you basically add an image you
submit an image and depending on what it
is it can be identified in a few minutes
or sometimes a few years it all depends
but usually someone will move it to an
appropriate place how I use it a lot is
if you go to the guide you can pick your
your insect group let's say insects
bdubs pick beatles for now you can go to
tax on you pick the family that you want
let's say you've got some sort of scarab
beetle and you want help identifying it
you can go to images and I'll just show
you general images but if you go to
browse it shows you the different
subfamily so you can quickly browse it
let's say okay I think I've got an
authority on dung beetle okay it narrows
it down further you can click on that
and go right down to species and for
each species you know there will be an
in San image the info for it and some of
them will have elaborate information on
on it and sort of habitat stuff some
will have a lot more information some
will have links and this is where it
gets really useful you can see the links
where you can get more information for
proper identification so if you went to
40 ions you'll see that link is the
really good one to identify things to
Jenna and then the species it depends
also for each species so you can also
google let's say you've got something on
siness caterpillar this sometimes can
work
gives you some of these images let's see
go to this one okay yeah it kind of
looks like that look at the range so
where they've got specimens from at an
Eastern thing it's in New York okay
that's reasonable here's the the time
you see it sort of think so this is I
think one of the most useful resources
for it not just that but also will link
to other useful resources so for this
particular species here's a link to moth
photographers group which has
information another website so several
websites that have further information
so basically beyond that start with bug
guide and it will if it doesn't have the
answer it will link you to the answer
and of course you can always submit to
the insect diagnostic lab as a general
rule for people relate to the cce if you
don't want to pay the 25 dollars if you
just want a yes or no answer I will do
that for free but for a what is this
answer I'll I do charge for that as long
as if you're expecting yes or no answer
if if maybe is an acceptable answer then
again yeah I can I can usually do those
for free and especially if it's
something rather quick like that and you
can find my contact info through the
insect diagnostic lab or just google me
I'm always keen to hear what various
educators get in other counties because
for a lot of the things that are easier
to identify I just I never hear about it
they just don't come across to me very
often so thank you so much this has been
a production of Cornell University on
the web at cornell edu